hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
ht tutorial in which i'll be showing you
a piece of freeware called desktube
which is actually a youtube viewing
client in which you don't actually go
into your browser and view youtube
videos but you can interact with
youtube.com through a piece of freeware
so let's just get right into this guys
so like i said before desktube is the
name of the piece of software and i'll
provide a link in the description for
you guys to go ahead and download this
piece of software but once you've
downloaded and installed it you will
actually have a number of shortcuts one
in your start menu one in your quick
launch bar and one on your desktop so
for the purpose of this tutorial i've
left the one on my desktop and here's
what it looks like so i'm going to
double click this so you guys can see
how long it takes to open
and just like that you've opened up
desktube so it's probably going to take
about as long as it does for youtube.com
to open there's actually a new release
bug fix but i'm going to cancel that so
i can get on with this tutorial and show
you guys some neat things about
desktube so this is desktube itself
basically you have a number of options
along the top a number of sub options uh
as kind of a second layer a search box
over here on the left hand side a
youtube player and some video uh
scanning you know privileges so up here
on the top obviously when you're signed
in you'll be able to view a number of
things you can hit the watch button to
simply watch videos hit playlist and
you'll go ahead and log in and i'll just
log into mkbhd0
and hit the login button and you'll be
able to view all your playlists i
actually don't have any playlists but
when you open one it opens in a separate
window which is actually a nice feature
in some cases but in other cases not so
much i'll get into that
so you have playlists you have your
subscriptions which also opens up in a
second window you have the ability to
record videos directly in here and
upload it to youtube so that's a great
feature something you would have
expected in a mac os x equivalent
such as quicktime x
you can upload videos from this client
you can also video chat and update your
twitter and facebook status in desktube
so one of the advantages of the desktube
desktop youtube video player is that you
can actually record and upload videos
directly from this client and it'll
actually be a pretty good speed and
quality too for example if you see the
record button up here on the right hand
side if you click this record button
it'll actually bring up this quick
capture widget in its own separate
window and you can go ahead and have
your preview right there so you can just
be dragging it to the top of the screen
where your webcam is and looking
directly at it and you'll be able to
record your video pressing that button
right there you can adjust volume grain
and video quality and then upload your
videos straight from there once you're
done recording obviously you can upload
it using this upload button right here
you select a file and you go ahead and
upload it and it's pretty darn quick
guys
so another thing that i like about the
desktop player is that you can actually
watch videos in a pop-out window which
is actually something that's been
available on youtube as a new feature
for about a month now and i kind of like
that you're able to do this say i'm
watching this jumbo fun video right here
in the main youtube player or the
desktube player all you have to do up at
the top right hand side is hit that
little arrow out button click it and
it'll open up your video in widescreen
high quality in a new video window so
you don't have to worry about any sort
of distractions while watching your
youtube video it's right there in the
middle your screen perfectly clean
desktop pop-out player and it works very
nicely when you're done watching the
video just exit out and it brings back
up the desktube home page
the last notable feature of the desktube
player are the subcategories underneath
the usual expected now as you guys know
youtube can sort its videos by top rated
top favorited most viewed etc you can
actually view these categories in the
desktop player and it's quite nicely
integrated all you have to do is select
your category by clicking
and it will sort them in the left hand
side by most view now these are mostly
of all time so we might want to change
that to
most viewed of a certain time period but
you get the point most discussed over
here on the right hand side or recently
featured etc all these videos will show
up in the left-hand side of the desktube
player
the last notable feature of the desktube
widget and also what i think is one of
the most uh interesting features is that
you can actually view a youtube video
before you click it meaning a small 10
to 15 second preview of the video before
you actually click on it to comment rate
and interact in other ways with the
video so go ahead and hover over the
thumbnail and you'll notice a red swipe
across and an audio and video playback
uh follows that and ends up being your
video preview
all you have to do is move your mouse
off of the preview and your preview is
pretty much played now you know if you
want to watch the video or not
so overall guys i really like the
desktube player it's it's looking pretty
flashy i like the way that it runs it's
very nice clean almost a metallic sort
of look so i do like the way it looks um
there are a few pros a few cons with
this player but overall i have to say if
i were to give this a hardware sort of
rating i know i don't do that often i
would give this an 8 out of 10. it's a
very solid player i'd give it a b
so um i'd like to thank you guys for
watching this hardware this software
review i apologize and i'm just going to
exit out of desktop here but if you guys
do want to download the software your
link will be in the description and i
hope you guys enjoyed this tutorial and
thank you for supporting the mkbhd
youtube channel and thank you for
watching this video so again talk to you
guys in the next video peace